منعنا من التصوير في هذه المنطقه وقال لنا
الجنود بان الدفاع الروسيه اصدرت بيانا
بمنع التصوير في كل مناطق نوبيكا خوفكا
هذه هي
المياه التي فاضت من سد نوفا خوفك وغمرت
المناطق السكنيه وكذلك مناطق اخرى
ندخل هذه المناطق بحذر حيث وصل منسوب
المياه كما نرى في بيت هذه العائله الى
مستوى مرتفع جدا هذه المنطقه بالفعل
غمرتها المياه بالكامل ونحن ننقل الصوره
لقناه العربيه والحدث من مدينه نوفا حيث
المياه التي جرفت كل ما صادفته في طريقها
بعد قصف محطه او سد نوفيكا الذي فاضت فيه
المياه وارتفع منسوبها الى هذه الدرجه
بالكاد حافظنا على الوثائق والاموال
والامتعه وعدنا اليوم لجمع ما نحتاج اليه
بدات المياه تتدفق بشكل مريع وكان صعبا
للغايه فعل اي شيء اسرعنا للحفاظ على ما
نحتاجه بعيدا عن المياه ونقلنا بعد
نسمع اصوات اطلاق الرصاص من حولنا وسقوط
القذائف والصواريخ طبعا
ايضا الكهرباء مقطوعه داخل المنزل
وفي المنطقه بشكل عام هو هذه اثار الطوفان
الذي وصل الى اطراف المدينه البعيده عن
السد بعد منتصف ليله امس توقفت المياه بعد
التيار القوي ومن ثم بدات بالانجراف وبدا
منسوب ارتفاعها بالتراجع قليلا والان
المياه ثابته عند هذا المستوى نحن هنا
نعيش منذ زمن طويل ونريد السلامه ان يعم
المنطقه
يحذرنا رجال الامن من انتشار الالغام التي
جرفتها السيول والفيضانات في جميع انحاء
هذه المنطقه حيث يمكن ان يتفجر لغم في اي
مكان وفي اي لحظه لقناتي العربيه والحدث
رائد الاغبر نوفا
الصينيه والوثائق وتقارير الاخباريه لا
تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا على اليوتيوب
الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل جرس
التنبيهات